there was an idea to bring together a
group of remarkable people so when they
needed us we could fight the battles
that they never could
[Music]
welcome back everyone its charlie
surprise surprise I was just working on
an Iron Man video and Marvel announced
that Iron Man is returning in the Black
Widow movie so we'll break it down we're
doing an Amazon giveaway all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best taskmaster theory on the video
because we're gonna be seeing taskmaster
in the MCU for the first time during the
black widow movie but as you all
probably suspected at the news it's
probably not iron man coming back from
the grave in present day of 2023 it's
probably iron man in the past because
pretty much all the black widow movie
takes place during a couple different
time periods in the past really like
three different time periods that we
know about because of a couple deleted
scenes I'll include those in the video
but we'll break it all down number three
late era iron man Black Widow so the
present day of the Black Widow movie
will be set after Captain America Civil
War but before Avengers infinity war
when Black Widow and Captain America's
Secret Avengers team that we saw during
infinity war were running around the
world dismantling illegal alien arms
traders and warlords they didn't really
get into what they had been doing the
last couple of years during Avengers
infinity war but they dealt with it in
the tie-in comics and it was just a
bigger version of what they did during
spider-man homecoming with the vulture
and the tinkerer repurposing and selling
Chitauri weaponry leftover from the
Avengers Battle of New York they were
localized to the tri-state area but the
people that Black Widow and Captain
America's Secret Avengers were going
after we're doing that on a global scale
also during that period while they're
running around the world on the DL Black
Widow left Captain America's team for a
while to go back to Russia for answers
about her past and because of the Jelena
Bulova Black Widow in the Red Room
program even though Natasha is the
character that we refer to when we talk
about Black Widow any of the people that
graduate from the Red Room officially
graduate as and they don't die during
the program become black widows so there
are many black widows during the Black
Widow movie there's a deleted scene
during Captain America Civil War that
addresses her going back to Russia to
learn about her past
when I came out of the ice I thought
everyone I had known was gone I found
out she was alive
I was just lucky to have her
she had you back too after everything
happened with shield during my little
hiatus I went back to Russia and tried
to find my parents
two little gravestones by a chain-link
fence I pulled some weeds and left some
flowers
we have what we have when we have it
who else signed it so black widows going
back to Russia to help her sister Jelena
Bulova Black Widow not biological sister
just one of the fellow black widows that
will appear during the movie
Rachel vices playing another one of the
black widows from the comics named
milena Voss - cough whose code name is
technically Iron Maiden probably one of
the meaner people during the film
although Black Widow spends most of the
early part of the Black Widow film
fighting Jelena Bulova before she starts
to help her so at the end of Captain
America Civil War
iron man was still on pretty decent
terms with Black Widow he was concerned
for her but really it was only Captain
America that he was super pissed off at
and even then he kind of backed off it
by the time cap gave him that message if
you ever need us call us on this really
weird cheap flip phones it's part of a
Chinese integration so that we can make
more money on this movie no joke that's
the reason why they used that Chinese
flip phone because they were marketing
the film in China so they wanted to get
some integration money that's why he's
using the janky flip phone when he has
way more advanced technology so Black
Widow could be drawing on resources from
Iron Man and getting help from him in
the present day of the movie this set
during that Captain America Civil War
period this is the deleted scene of her
talking to Tony Wright as she was
getting ready to take off for the last
time during that movie
must be hard to shake a double agent
thing that sticks in the DNA are you
incapable of letting go of your ego from
one goddamn second
T'Challa told Ross what she did so I'm
not the one that needs to watch their
back but number two more likely
flashback Ironman to the 90s when he was
still drinking partying selling all
kinds of weapons to the highest bidder
the flashback at the beginning of Iron
Man 3
that was 90s Ironman during that period
Black Widow would have been at the
height of her early career running all
over the world assassinating people on
the orders of the Red Room she could
cross paths with Ironman during one of
those flashbacks also important she had
a relationship with Red Guardian who's
another character during the movie when
she was still working with the Russian
government younger version of Black
Widow he's being played by David Harbor
sheriff hopper himself what a
coincidence that his Marvel name is
Alexi after stranger things season 3 but
Red Guardian is actually pretty big
character from the comics he's the
Russian version of Captain America he
was dosed with a derivative of the Super
Soldier Serum based on tech that they
stole from the Americans in Howard Stark
they could wind up showing a flashback
to the black widows stealing the Super
Soldier Serum from Howard Stark further
back in the past because Howard Stark is
one of the few people from that period
that would still have records about what
they did to Captain America to turn him
into Captain America but number one most
likely Iron Man scene early theory is
that at the end of the Black Widow movie
Hawkeye shows up in Budapest with orders
to kill Black Widow but instead sees
that she's not a bad person
takes pity on her and offers her a shot
at redemption clearing the red off of
her ledger and brings her into net fury
to join shield during that meeting Nick
Fury gives her her first assignment
which is infiltrating Iron Man's
organization for the purposes of
scouting him for the Avengers initiative
so maybe her final scene in the Black
Widow movie winds up being a callback to
her very first appearance in the MCU
which was Iron Man 2 when she showed up
under the fake name Natalie rushman to
watch Iron Man
an Ironman to the part that appealed to
me most about her lose her dedication
and just her intelligence I think you
need some more people and it will be
like that there's too much up for grabs
there's too many things are change and
you need somebody who's gonna be a
steward of their character cordon off
all access to the track and for the
airspace we're here Denise we got it
okay scarlet was was just a dream you
know she's so game and she had a really
good time doing it
unlike some of us older curmudgeons
there's very little you can do to get
under her skin she's just consummately
professional I loved playing this
character and we first met Natasha and
Iron Man - she was Natalie and you know
you've got to see her kind of undercover
work and you know it wasn't until the
end of that phone the true identity was
revealed as an agent of shield you are
mind blowing just how do you do it you
just tear things that you're a triple
imposter I've never seen anything like
is there anything real about you do you
speak Latin feel like you're soon Trewin
spec is which means wait what what you
just say
means you can either drive yourself home
or I can have you clever either way I
think we can all agree they're
definitely gonna have a moment with
Hawkeye in Budapest they haven't
confirmed Gerry renner cameo and they
haven't confirmed Winter Soldier cameo
I've seen a lot of theories that Winter
Soldier is secretly going to be
taskmaster but I'm kind of hoping that's
not the case because that would burn
another really cool villain character
that they could use on a Thunderbolt
steam if they do a Thunderbolts movie or
a thunderbolt series wouldn't you want
to see taskmaster come back in present
day so hopefully he doesn't get killed
at the end of the Black Widow movie the
reason why I think that they're gonna
have a Hawkeye scene is because their
final scene together on Vermeer before
she wound up sacrificing herself
directly addressed a scene in Budapest
that had incredible meaning for her that
we've never seen before so it makes
sense that they would try to include
that in some way during the Black Widow
movie I don't judge people in their wars
mistakes
maybe you didn't so just to be clear
this is not iron man rising from the
grave in 2023 coming back to the MCU any
scene that he has during the Black Widow
movie would be for a flashback Iron Man
2 flashbacks just make the most sense
but post all your theories in the
comments below
the next big black widow trailer is
probably gonna post sometime in late
November early December just like the
last Avengers and gain trailer in
infinity war of the year before that but
I'll remind people because they're
probably a couple teasers before then
congratulations constant Janek three
you're the giveaway winner from my last
big Marvel video please email me on the
about page of my channel so I can get
your contact details I just got done
posting a video for a long-lost Avengers
deleted post-credit scene referencing
x-men back during Marvel phase one it
blew everyone's minds click here to
watch that and click here for my new
venom 2 teaser with carnage in
spider-man crossover news thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]